mein name ist sebastian vor bach und
mein thema heute es ist genau in einer
woche so weit dann ist meine zweite
impfung exakt sechs monate her und was
passiert dann wissen sie ich weiß es
auch nicht wirklich geld die noch als
geimpft habe ich noch den vollständigen
impfschutz wie geht es weiter in anderen
ländern ist es deutlich klarer zum
beispiel in israel da müsste nach sechs
monaten jetzt mein dritter pigs her wie
sitz in deutschland aus schauen wir mal
auf die zahlen 1,8 millionen deutsche
haben ihre booster impfung erhalten 6,1
millionen bräuchten den dritten stich
damit sind wir weit hinter vielen
ländern in belgien und frankreich sind
doppelt so vielen menschen zum dritten
mal geben und ich finde da gehört viel
mehr informationen her wer benötigt auf
jeden fall die dritte impfung nach sechs
monaten das ist laut stiko mitbürger
über 70 vulnerable gruppen und menschen
die mit johnson johnson geimpft worden
sind wo bleibt da die
informationskampagne noch
gesundheitsministerien sparen hat sich
gerade auffrischen lassen und danach
getwittert toll damit fühlen sich sicher
menschen über 70 ganz toll informiert
und denen gefällt das wo sind die briefe
in den briefkasten wo es die
impfkampagne wo sind die plakate
42 prozent aller corona patienten in den
krankenhäusern über 60 jahre sind
doppelt geimpft daher mein appell wir
verspielen aktuell zeit wir verspielen
krankenhaus kapazitäten und rennen
richtung neuer maßnahmen startet endlich
eine neue impfkampagne
für sebastian da sprichst du ich glaube
jahren aus dem herz aber ich frage mich
wirklich was da los ist du sagst ja 62
prozent derer die da auf den krankenhaus
fluren und in den krankenhäusern wir
jetzt werden den intensivstationen 42 43
21 auf schlimm sind doppelt geimpft das
ist natürlich alles wasser auf die
mühlen auf all derer die da gesagt haben
das ist mir ziemlich skurril was mit
diesem impfstoff da passiert denn uns
wurde ja gesagt lasst euch einmal impfen
mit dem einen impfstoff oder mit
biontech oder was auch immer wir sind ja
alle hier geimpft die von aus also dann
habt ihr erst mal hoch so um das
passiert 42 prozent derer die doppelt
geimpft sind oder geimpft sind
allerdings jetzt schon wieder im
krankenhaus
wir werden tatsächlich nicht nur
drangsaliert an uns wird appelliert und
booster impfen zu lassen und all
diejenigen die sowieso schon probleme
hatten mit dem impfen sagen wie kann
denn das sein und das muss man verstehen
und da braucht es natürlich mehr
aufklärung ab 70 heißt es manche sagen
ab 60 sah man sich impfen lass ich weiß
gar nicht gibt es genügend impfstoff der
bundesgesundheitsminister sagt ja er
lässt sich mit 41 jahren impfen weil er
ja auch ein kurve erkrankt war und nur
diesen einen im pixar hatte das gilt
offenbar auch bei ihm da als als
ausnahme oder als risikogruppe darf sich
also impfen lassen trotzdem so viele
unwägbarkeiten denn die alle wasser auf
die mühlen sind derer die eine impf
skepsis haben deswegen brauchen wir
klarheit wir brauchen fakten und waren
auch jemand der das mal beantworten kann
auch da kann es auch nicht sein dass der
gesundheitsminister jetzt
wittert und sondern da brauchen wir
wirklich eine kampagne die alle erreicht
vor allen dingen wenn man sich anschaut
lauterbach hat das vor einigen tagen
getwittert wie sehr die booster impfung
wirkt das biotech auf buy und sex sind
glaube ich 13 das dreizehnfache
wirkungen und bei kauf moderner müssen
andere erklären warum gegenüber 17 fache
wirkungen das ist dass das phänomen das
wir ja sowieso bei den meisten
impfstoffen haben und das ist ja auch
die aufforderung die jetzt gekommen ist
dass man eben diese kreuz impfung quasi
macht wenn man die astrazeneca impfungen
die sollen ja ohnehin jetzt einem
impfstoff im besten fall noch nachholen
johnson & johnson müssen wir jetzt auch
dass es sinn ergibt das doppelt impfen
zu lassen ich möchte auf jeden fall dir
in einem punkt ganz toll recht geben ich
glaube dass wir bei kampagnen gerade was
den gesundheitsbereich angeht deutlich
noch nachholen können und das haben wir
einmal bei den organspendeausweis
gesehen die impfkampagne die lief ganz
gut die brauchen wir vor allem jetzt
nochmal aber das war meines erachtens
auch schon in der ersten welle der
impfung der fall dass wir überhaupt
keine impfung keine infos haben und ich
hätte mir so eine brief kampagne
tatsächlich videos angesprochen
also eine informationskampagne oder mit
aufklärungskampagnen
definitiv nicht geschadet übrigens wenn
man es ist interessant in dem
zusammenhang sich etwas genauer
anzuschauen was sie im ausland so alles
passiert also ich glaube belgien und
frankreich sind deutlich weiter als wir
ich selbst war am anfang des sommers in
israel und dort gab es schon eine
kampagne eine öffentliche debatte
darüber ob überhaupt irgendjemand sich
mit dem thema bei uns beschäftigt hat
also von daher sieht man es geht anders
aber da waren andere deutlich weiter als
wir dabei sieht er nicht diesen punkt
wären wir gesagt haben die ganze zeit
doppelt impfen reicht lasst euch mal
doppelt impfen aber wo kommt jetzt aus
der kiste her der booster also nach dem
motto es reicht alles nicht das was karl
lauterbach gesagt hat ist ja richtig und
bei allem respekt wir finden alle also
karl lauterbach glaube ich wirklich hat
ein großes großes fachwissen nur er ist
natürlich im verdacht ein absoluter
impfbefürworter zu sein wenn der jetzt
sagt die dritte impfung hilft dann sagt
mir häuser klar karl lauterbach der bild
sie wieder zum fixen zwingen nicht also
da würde es wirklich mich mal
interessieren wo sind die wirkliche
wissenschaftlichen fakten die das
belegen damit wir auch hier eine klare
klare antwort haben ob darum warum das
alles so toll ist und so gut
funktioniert der will mich zum impfen
zwängen sich ganzjährig in dem
zusammenhang aber genau das was
sebastian kranke system druckt ja das
ist der eindruck der bei vielen entsteht
aber es gibt de facto keinen impfzwang
dass wir nicht deswegen auch direkt
wieder ausräumen weil ich diesen begriff
bezogen auf die krone impfung nicht sein
kann es gibt de facto keinen zwang durch
die angst soll mir ich bin kein
impfgegner wir sagen eigentlich angeben
ist aber durch die angst ist bei vielen
das muss man einfach nur verstehen ich
glaube das argument kann man auch nicht
nur tot machen indem man es negiert
sondern bei denen ihnen die sorgen haben
und so kommt jetzt der eindruck genau
wir haben ja keine belastbaren fakten
was du sagst das ist doch unser großes
wird leben ohnehin denn es um die
impfungen für corona ging ich meine wir
haben lange und breite natürlich auch in
der chemisch debatte darüber geredet
dass es eben noch keine langzeitstudien
gibt aber einen impfstoff den es
vielleicht nach anderen seit anderthalb
jahren gibt natürlich gibt es da noch
keine weitreichenden langzeitstudien
aber die wissenschaft kann uns schon
jetzt sagen dass die folge für schäden
vergleichbar mit anderen impfstoffen
sind das ist natürlich dann immer so
eine abwägungsfrage ich glaube das was
sebastian gesagt hat diese 17-fache
booster ich bin ein corona erkrankt und
ich weiß wie mein täter danach aussah
kurz danach man kann das glaub ich so
einen monat danach dann testen und ich
weiß auch wie der titel aussah bevor ich
mich impfen lassen und ich weiß wie er
danach aussah und ich sehe schon dass
die impfung noch mal ordentlich was
drauf legt auf meine körpereigenen
antikörper und eine booster impfung kann
da noch mal was nachgeben was ich aber
interessant finden im zug ist also neben
den impf durchbrüchen die wir nun mal
leider aktuell viel haben scheint es
aktuell auch viele zu geben das ist
jetzt mal nur dahin gestellt und
wissenschaftlich glaube ich überhaupt
nicht belegt aber ohne viele zu geben
die danach dann an corona nach dem
booster erkranken oder zumindest
positiven pcr-test vorweisen vielleicht
auch natürlich bei die virenlast im
körper dann größer ist aber das fand ich
auch sehr interessant das sind ja aber
genau die linken die aufgeklärt werden
müssen dann kommt noch ein logistisches
problem dazu denn es gibt ja viel
impfzentren die vielerorts geschlossen
sind weil die finanzierung nicht mehr
klar ist weil auch gedacht wurde gut
jetzt haben wir relativ diejenigen die
wollten haben wir gekämpft da knapp 70
prozent jetzt brauchen wir nicht mehr
wohl gehe ich also hin für den booster
und das führt wird ja alles auf die
hausärzte junger mann abgeschoben aber
ich frage mich warum gibt es keine
informationskampagne während sich das
universum ist sind sollte das
gesundheitsministerium ist dafür
zuständig warum gibt es das aktuell
nicht ist es glatt dieser nimbus dass
die regierung nur geschäftsführend im
amt ist und in den koalitionsgesprächen
hat man gerade wichtigeres anleihen zu
besprechen ich glaube also korrigiert
mich gerne wenn ich falsch liege gerade
sie als ehemalige regierungssprecher
wissen das besser als ich wenn 1 comment
koalitionsverhandlungen stattfinden eine
regierung nur noch geschäftsführend im
amt ist darf sie keine weiteren aufträge
vergeben und auch keine weiteren
beschäftigung anfangen das ist natürlich
ein großes problem weil man für
kampagnen agenturen anstalt in der regel
was macht man im ministerium nicht von
sich aus ich glaube dass das da auf
jeden fall mit reinspielen aber die
regierung ist ja erst seit einigen tagen
geschäftsführer der deutsche bundestag
hat sich erst am dienstag konstituiert
also vorher gab sie auch eine offizielle
amtierende regierung und es ist ja nicht
so dass wir dass wir diese kampagne oder
diese aufklärungskampagne erst oder die
notwendigkeit einer solchen kampagne
erst seit mittwoch sehen sondern das
thema war ja vor ich und da und
offensichtlich hat man sich damit nicht
beschäftigt schade sie sind ja beide
dass man zu viel nachwuchs politiker
innen nennt also in daher immer
die quasi neuen ansatz abend das aber
was mich daran ärgert an dieser politik
ist doch auch so dieses na ja gut wir
sind aber wir sind nicht zuständig da
aus juristischen gründen bedarf nichts
vergeben aber lasst sie doch selber ist
bisschen auch darin fertig werden mit
all den problemen die es jetzt gibt also
dass wir nicht sagt hier regiert jetzt
das gesamtgesellschaftliche interesse
und wir lassen das mal beiseite setzen
uns zusammen sagen hey es gibt hier die
erfordernis die bevölkerung zu
informieren darüber nach was können wir
tun und wenn dann die regierungen die
wahrscheinlich ins amt kommen wird sagte
lasst mal sein dann hat man hier immer
sogar noch ein politisches mittel zu
sagen ihr seid hier ganz auf dem
falschen dampfer ihr wollt nicht dass
wir die menschen informieren aber diese
schwelle sollte man schon überschreiten
ja alles machen kann